هل خرجت من أي وقت مضى من مبنى
في يوم مشمس وكان لديك رغبة لا يمكن السيطرة
عليها للعطس
إذا أجبت بنعم مثلي ، فمن المحتمل أنك
تعاني من حالة وراثية
غريبة ظلت غير مفسرة من قبل
العلوم الطبية لآلاف السنين ، وإذا
أجبت بـ "لا" فربما يكون لديك  لا توجد فكرة
عما أتحدث عنه من عطاس الابن
لأنه أكثر شيوعًا هو حالة طبية
تسمى منعكس العطس الضوئي
قبل أن ندخل في كل
ما هو د.  لويس بوتا تشاك ، اختصاصي
الأعصاب وعالم الوراثة البشرية في
جامعة كاليفورنيا سان فرانسيسكو ،
حسنًا ، تفضل بالاسم الآخر الذي
أطلقه البعض على
الجسد المهيمن الجسيم الهيليو العيني أو
متلازمة عدم الاختيار ، لكن PSR هو حقًا
الاسم المناسب الذي يجب أن نستخدمه جميعًا
منعكس العطس الضوئي هو  الميل إلى
العطس عند التعرض المفاجئ لأضواء ساطعة
وغريبًا قد يبدو
أنه أكثر شيوعًا مما قد تعتقد أنني
طلبت مقابلة ذلك حوالي واحد من كل عشرة أو
عشرة في المائة من جميع الأشخاص يعانون من هذه
الحالة ، لذلك يتأثر الكثير منا
ولكن  كيف ولماذا يحدث هذا غير
مفهوم تمامًا على الرغم من حقيقة أن البشر
كانوا يفكرون في الأمر منذ آلاف
السنين في 350 قبل الميلاد طرح أرسطو
السؤال لماذا تثير حرارة الشمس
العطس ، كان أرسطو
ينبح الشجرة الخطأ على الرغم من أن هذا لا
يبدو منطقيًا لأن الحرارة في حد ذاتها
ليست مدهشة بعد حوالي 2000
عام ، حاول الفيلسوف السير فرانسيس
بيكون
أيضًا معرفة  كانت نظريته
هي أن الضوء من الشمس يتسبب
في تسرب الماء إلى
عينيك مما يؤدي إلى العطس ، إنها
فكرة مثيرة للاهتمام ولكنها لا تعني
الكثير من
حدوث PSR على الفور تقريبًا
ويستغرق وقتًا أطول للقنوات الدمعية  للرد
علاوة على ذلك ، لا تسبب الدموع العطس
، ولا يوجد دليل على ذلك ، لذا
فقد توصل الطب الحديث إلى
نظرياته
الخاصة ويتعلق بالأسلاك في رأسك
، وعادة ما يتم تشغيل العطس عن طريق
تهيج الأشياء في
أنفنا ويتم اكتشافها بواسطة
العصب العصب ثلاثي التوائم والمجاور
للعصب ثلاثي التوائم هو العصب البصري
الذي ربما سمعت عنه ،
يتم تحفيز العصب البصري بواسطة الأضواء الساطعة
ويرسل إشارات كهربائية إلى الدماغ
يمكن التقاط بعض هذه الإشارة
بواسطة البكاء.  العصب الذي يساء تفسيره من
قبل الدماغ على أنه تهيج في
الأنف يدفعك إلى
التفكير في العطس جيدًا ، وهذه هي النظرية على أي حال ، فإن
منعكس العطس ليس مرضًا
وبالتالي
لم يهتم المجتمع الطبي به كثيرًا
، لذلك لا نعرف سوى القليل جدًا
عن أسبابه ولكن د.
يعتقد باتاشنيك أن فهم PSR يمكن
أن يغلق بعض الضوء على الحالات الأكثر
خطورة
يمكن أن تحدث نوبات الصرع بسبب الأضواء الوامضة.
مهم طبيًا
ويمثل الاضطرابات ، لذلك لديك
هذا اللغز الطبي الذي يبلغ من العمر 2000 عام والذي قد
يستحق الحل بعد كل شيء